comment vivre les épidémies comme le co
vide avec philosophie
ça c'est la grosse question comment
vivent les épidémies comme le co vide
avec philosophie bas d'abord en prenant
conscience du fait que la philosophie
nom laisse pas tomber malade
ce que la pile de fil nous aide à faire
c'est accepter d'être mortel montaigne
décrit très très joliment est très
fortement d'une meurt pas de ce que tu
es malade humeur de ce que tu es vivant
comme andy la mort fait partie de la vie
il n'y a pas moyen d'aimer la vie sans
accepter la mort puisque la mort est
indissociable de la vie et donc il
s'agit d'accepter d'être mortel
d'accepter notre propre finitude
dans les essais montaigne écrit
exactement ceci je veux qu'on agisse et
qu'on prolonge les offices de la vie
tant qu'on peut et que la mort me trouve
plantant meshoe mais nonchalant d'elles
est encore plus de mon jardin un parc
voilà je veux qu'on agisse y compris
contre la connerie 19 ours protégez vous
cherchez un vaccin chercher un
médicament ça ça relève de l'action et
qu'on prolonge les deux fils de la vie
tant qu'on peut autrement dit plus on
vit longtemps mieux ça vaut tant que la
vie reste que tu portable donc je veux
qu'on agisse et qu'on prolonge deux fils
de la vie tant qu'on peut et que la mort
me trouve plantant michaud c'est à dire
dans l'action précisément pas en train
de l'attendre paralysé de peur et que la
mort me trouve plantant meshoe mais
nonchalant d'elles est encore plus de
mon jardin un parfait la nonchalance
chez montaigne
c'est le contraire et de la forclusion
de la mort ceux qui veulent ni pensé à
mettre qui font tout pour oublier qu'ils
sont mortels et contre eux montagne
écrit ils vont ils viennent il trotte il
danse de mort nu le nouvel ils font tout
pour billets qu'ils vont mourir une en
mourront pas moins donc la nonchalance
et le contraire de la forclaz namor et
c'est le contraire de l'obsession de la
mort les gens qui ne pensent plus qu'à
ça
il s'agit pas d'oublier la mortalité il
s'agit pas d'en être obsédé il s'agit de
l'accepter sereinement de l'accepter
avec nonchalance comme on accepte sa
propre imperfections
sa propre finitude notre jardin parfait
chez montaigne c'est notre vie
simplement
mais voilà montaigne nous aide à
accepter d'être mortel a accepté que la
vie relève de la finitude accepter notre
propre imperfections et c'est pourquoi
il nous donne des leçons de sagesse
montaigne a connu deux catastrophes
majeures les guerres de religion la
peste nous nous avons le terrorisme et
la codi de 19 c'est quand même dans les
deux cas moins graves que du temps de
montaigne
raison de plus pour profiter de cette
leçon de sagesse que nous donne montel
qui se résume en une phrase à la fin des
essais montaigne écrit pour moi donc
j'aime la vie je crois que c'est la plus
belle définition de la sagette la vraie
sagesse pour montaigne
ce n'est pas l'amour du bonheur ce n'est
pas l'amour de la sagesse la vraie
sagesse et l'amour de la vie heureuse ou
malheureuse
ça joue pas et bien sûr aucune vie n'est
jamais heureuse ou sage dans son entier
et c'est où l'on retrouve l'idée de
d'accepter notre finitude accepter notre
mortalité accepter notre imperfection
c'est la seule façon de vivre à peu près
heureux c'est à dire
[Musique]